peut-être que justement le brésil aura
une vertu pour nous européens c'est que
c'est une opportunité de changer
complètement la construction européenne
et y'a de quoi faire parce que la vérité
c'est que il faudra analyser jeu
peut-être on le fera ici les les raisons
exactes de la sortie de titanic parce
qu'il ya plein de causes y compris à des
choses troublantes
toutes les consultations sur l'europe
des mondes qui a des fractures fractures
territoriales entre les métropoles et
les zones périurbaines fracture de
classe aussi les ouvriers évidemment ils
votent plus pour le mais c'est
intéressant voir ça c'est comme un toute
l'europe et de ce point de vue là il ya
quand même leur fait pas envie quoi